[Music]
this is something that actually happened
in december
but the details were covered up
until
four days ago
it was a prison riot that happened in a
las vegas jail whoa and the prison tried
to cover it up for the any of the info
getting out they just hit a whole riot
i think i mean there's a lot of reasons
why they covered it up but we'll get to
that um they probably had like a jail
like cirque show and start doing their
own circus shows in there
because all the people in jail there are
impersonators and car dealers so let me
let me tell you a little bit about the
complexity of this riot okay that boys
of circ so here's what happened all at
the same time
um the inmates in this one unit unlocked
their own cells from inside
refused orders covered all the
surveillance cameras flooded the whole
area with water out of the toilets and
they took control of the entire unit
they took a metal bunk bed frame and
jammed the door while they all got into
formation
as soon as the cos and the uh um all the
guards burst through the door
the the inmates were in the mirrored
version of their formation wow so then
they were behind them no i mean like so
there's a there's a protocol of
formation that these guards are going to
get in once this happens the inmates
were in like like a football player like
ready to receive them yeah exactly so
they knew this like thing what the [ __ ]
and then that's organized and the
ringleader was a known white supremacist
from the aryan warrior gang they um they
end up getting taken down with tasers
pepper balls flashbangs grenades all
kinds of things and uh they ended up
basically quelling the riot but none of
the info uh got out of the jail i mean
don't they doesn't that happen like a
lot like riots and stuff and then like
they just have to move on basically what
happened is the guards um
they were really unequipped to deal with
this riot also they look like fools and
they look like yeah they look bad but
also uh the guards kind of felt like
they needed some form of justice for
like putting them in that situation and
the jail not doing anything to like
remedy that and instead kept it quiet so
that it wouldn't get out that their
resources were low oh because then they
see a vulnerability in the so did the
guards go back and get revenge and beat
up the inmates or something well now
that the news is out now all that
stuff's starting to come into play where
all these like all the families of these
guards and everybody's starting to make
a lot of noise about it damn
well see the two the whole thing is
a lot of these prisons are
under-equipped and then
um you know there's certain things as
far as conditions that are going on that
they're not addressing like it could
have been a food situation we were at an
institution in california city when i
first opened up and there was a [ __ ]
show so when they told us to lock it
down at one point nobody locked it down
and they're like so there's a protest it
was like basically a protest and so
people uh nobody locked it down
everybody set out to fail that you know
the warden came they had the guards and
they were kind of like like looking and
they didn't really want to come in there
because there wasn't enough of them and
then you know they eventually i guess
reinforce reinforcements finally came
and then they somehow i can't remember
how they coerced everybody to get back
into the cell but then at that point
like dude he went like it was almost
like a day and a half two days with a
little food like they didn't bring the
food you know i mean so like that was
like oh you guys want to play them games
and there's no way for us to communicate
anything you know but you're way out in
the middle of california city a desert
this facility is under-equipped they
don't they're just the only and they
only had minimal inmates there because
see they have funding for these prisons
and in order to keep getting that money
they got to have people there so they
shift people around and it's like
chattel like they keep moving you around
so you go from san bernardino they send
you over here to kern county they'll see
you over in california city so that then
when they do a census galaxy they got to
do a simpsons count
everywhere in california at four o'clock
you got to stand up and do a count and
that count gives them a number that they
put into a
census which allows them to continue
funding these facilities if they don't
have people in those places they get
closed down they lose the funding and
they lose the job so they want to keep
those places open because it's providing
money for that community which is a
source of income so it's a [ __ ]
racket to move bodies around so they
might have two three hundred like
islanders or so many people here from
the feds and they put them over here to
hold them they do a count they do that
for a while they send them over here to
borrow them do account and they keep
moving around and it's a game so these
prisons are scams bro they don't even
need all these prisons open but they
want to continue to make it seem like
they want to employ and have these
people these guards want jobs
so
rather than shut down these places and
provide adequate
food and and necessities and resources
in the places they do have to improve
the conditions they have shitty places
open with minimal staff minimal food
options and basically it's horrendous
bro it's like you're eating like sambar
you know the food is it's horrible
horrible bro and the guards have been
there you can't trade food you can't
look at them it's filthy there's roaches
and [ __ ] it's nasty the sales is dirty
and it's barbaric you can't trade food
like i heard people make spread and all
that but not in san bernardino county
like we're in the kitchen and like say
you're one you're like looking at the
food because you're just you're not
eating it and i'm starving i don't have
no food because a new a top ramen one
top ramen costs a dollar something one
top ramen and you're starving and if
they see you pass food they'll [ __ ] you
up
vicious man so the the whole thing with
the food because the food is your most
precious commodity so i can guarantee
they'll do the maybe i can't guarantee
but
probabilities are there was over food
because we didn't lock it down one time
or we refused to come out in another
institution because of food because they
started giving us rations to try to see
i'm like oh these are good enough for
the middle you guys can eat these and
people are like man [ __ ] that we're
doing tommy oh and then people said
we're not coming out and then after like
a week because he if a facility doesn't
operate for x amount of hours
basically they come in and they shut it
down and lose their funding and people
do the job so they like you better come
out we're going to shake this
[ __ ] up we're going to tear this
place you got to be shipped all over the
country you better come out then they
call the reps from each each gang or
each or each click or car and they try
to get them to come back and offer them
something look tell your guys to come
out we're going to give you watermelon
hamburgers union negotiations yeah you
get the negotiation yeah yeah that's how
they do it
come out all right come out you know i
mean but if you come out when they're
telling you not to come out like they're
the white dude oh they're like hey get
yourself i'm a shower [ __ ] you okay we
come off the vlog down
you're right you're gonna get [ __ ] up
do all the cars communicate like all the
races get together and say let's all do
this yeah white black asian
hispanic
everybody [ __ ] blood you know everybody
come together because it's a it's your
food is your only thing that's your only
your only source of pleasure so if you
don't have no food you can eat i mean do
what else you live for most of the
rights are food related yes
what are they feeding y'all in there oh
man horrible food man some of the places
like i remember
i was at a place at sheridan initially
they had like you know he's give you
eggs and stuff like couple times a week
you'd have weekends as nice food and you
know and or during the week you would
have these other pancake dishes this
warden came in from marion a cold piece
of [ __ ] a brother at that man cold piece
of [ __ ] he looked around and they didn't
have hardly any barbed wire they used to
have like like concerts like people
would play music and stuff he came in
and first thing he did was start [ __ ]
with the food he went from like the eggs
and all this other stuff to like
um like straight grits and like
uh honey buns like these just sugar [ __ ]
see they're they're like
your food i can kill you with it
nutrition wise so if i start giving you
[ __ ] food you get miserable you're angry
because you don't like [ __ ] i ain't got
no food and this and that so it's also
a way to control emotions and eventually
that ward when he did that a riot it
ended up kicking off some [ __ ] kicked
off there he created all that purposely
to justify all the spending that the
funding they needed to continue
whatever programs he wanted to do there
and he got rid of whatever other
programs got rid of the weights got
where you know a bunch of stuff oh he's
a piece of [ __ ] but they they play these
games man and i can tell you right now
that the same games they play in there
are the ones they play here food
shortage two packs of meat and you go
the same thing there prison you ain't
got they take shut off the comments
there you go there they starve you out
it's the same as the micro the macro
they can practice in there yeah and see
look same thing asian are they getting
along with the blacks how's the mexicans
get one they can play it out here out
here using media oh racism asians in
oakland got jumped by a black guy oh
white guy shot over here it's the same
[ __ ] same [ __ ] they stir it up but they
play it out here and i'm watching them
fold them like [ __ ] this is prison like
when they close all the gyms i'm like
how they gonna close the gyms they took
the weights
they took the weights on the street bro
i couldn't believe it
i'm like never in my mind i'm like i was
so happy to be free and lift world waste
gyms are closed what the [ __ ] yeah dude
this is prison [ __ ] dude this is a cold
game it's the same gaming play in prison
they tell them look they meet with the
governors okay this institution in
california this one in oklahoma this is
what happened we put this many blacks
from here this many asians okay we
brought this shot call right here
he stirred it up because the blacks
don't like him he's aryan brother they
play with the people so what they do
put this on the news talk about this do
this over here start this that's a
creative ride in this town they're not
stupid they play it they got it down to
a science man and if you say that people
go conspiracy yes
we've been doing all big hercules
[ __ ]
you're on that [ __ ]
[ __ ] but they said always man i'm
telling you man they do that and one of
the things they always say like they
should ask me because i had a it was i
had a korean abolision white dude black
dude white dude uh mexican and we should
be studying all the time and they should
be like man what are you doing in there
what are you guys studying why you know
you always you got all these different
people hanging out and they were jealous
because i had all the race different
races coming together but we were small
but we all shared information they don't
want that communication they want
everybody angry oh see the blacks are
attacking asians now you didn't tell me
all of a sudden we never have no beef
for no what is this going on here then
it shows this it's like they stir up
[ __ ] because they create something to
create a reaction and people don't think
they don't even look at the whole get
the whole story that guy oh the police
they shot him what a guy he didn't see
that he was he was fighting he was going
to get a gun and he was a rapist he
didn't want to go to prison for the rape
charge so there's a lot of other [ __ ]
but they don't explain everything and
then you don't find out two months later
oh dude that was a [ __ ] old video
from 2009 and they made it look like it
was new and everyone just forgets you
know what the real conspiracy is how the
dudes get so buff on top ramen
yeah what's your macros like
protein bro no one's getting bro someone
have an [ __ ] like this big to stuff a
thing of protein in jail yeah like a
protein powder
always wonder that but like because
you're just
resting
you're growing
so you work out and you just work out
you hit it hard huh you hit it hard and
then the thing too like i think to a
degree people over
over
value like that that's they're like as
far as protein because if you're getting
minimal protein but you're carbon up and
you're able to rest you're recovering so
you're not really taxing your muscle
much because you're locked down and
you're sleeping a lot more and babies
grow when they sleep so the buff the
size you get is different it's not
ripped because it's huge though but
you're going to get mass the recovery
recovery is the key so it's not the
training everybody think oh man or the
food the food to a degree so if you're
able to predominantly in there the hot
major source of protein is like if you
can get like eggs from the kitchen and
tuna fish and or canned chicken you know
and you can eat a high diet like that
but the feedings are consistent
throughout the day but you're not like
you're not running the streets you're
not [ __ ] yeah
you know what i mean so you're you're
preserved
oh it's all beating up you know
everything's building up but if you're
already drinking flying uh man you're
not recovering you're working all the
time and president are you doing the
dudes who are buffing they're out there
for you know two three movements you
know like an hour and something then
they go and they eat and then they'll
lay down and it's relaxing your sediment
so your body's just recuperating where
you wouldn't normally recuperate from a
workout with that minimal nutrition
that's what i probably do
i just need to eat top ramen and go to
sleep and do a couple of push-ups with
some tuna though it's a tuna next time
you're at the gym just laying on the mat
what are you doing i'm covered
trying to get swole dog
[Music]
you